♪ ♪
>> Greg: AMERICA, OUR PRAYERS
HAVE BEEN ANSWERED.
ALEC BALDWIN SAYS HE IF HE RAN
FOR PRESIDENT, HE WOULD WIN.
>> IF IRAN, I WOULD WIN.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> WHY DON'T YOU RUN?
>> WHY DON'T YOU RUN FOR
PRESIDENT AS DONALD TRUMP?
>> IF IRAN FOR PRESIDENT, I
WOULD WIN HANDS DOWN.
THE FUNNIEST, MOST EXCITING,
CRAZIEST CAMPAIGN.
>> Greg: THIS, FRIENDS, IS THE
ELECTION THIS COUNTRY NEEDS AND
THE MEDIA DESERVES.
COULD YOU ASK FOR A BETTER MATCH
UP?
DONALD TRUMP AND A GUY WHO MAKES
A LIVING AS DONALD TRUMP.
ALTHOUGH HE'S NEVER RUN A
BUSINESS, HE HAS PLAYED SOMEONE
WHO HAS.
DID ANYONE SEE "BOSS BABY?"
I KID.
BALDWIN IS WAY MORE THAN AN
IMPERSONATOR.
HE'S AN ACTOR.
HE HAS MORE IN COMMON WITH
TRUMPED ANY THINGS.
HE'S A FAMOUS, BLUSTERY, EGO
DRIVEN NEW YORKER AND HE CARES
HOPEFULLY ENOUGH TO APPOINT SEAN
PENN AS HIS RUNNING MATE.
HERE'S A BIG POINT, ALEC.
YOU HATE THIS PRESIDENT AND YOU
FEEL WHERE THE PRESIDENT IS
HEADED.
MAKES IT HARD TO REMEMBER YOUR
LINES.
YOU SEE WHAT HE DOES TO YOUR
FRIENDS.
>> OF COURSE I WANT TO PUNCH HIM
IN THE FACE.
>> YES.
>> I HAVE THOUGHT AN AWFUL LOT
ABOUT BLOWING UP THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME AN
ACTOR ASSASSINATED A PRESIDENT?
>> Greg: THEY ARE A MESS.
ALL OF YOUR FRIENDS ARE
DESTROYING THEMSELVES.
YOU'VE GOT TO RUN.
YOU'VE GOT TO DO IT FOR THEM
BEFORE THEY LOSE IT COMPLETELY.
IF YOU FEEL THAT STRONGLY ABOUT
STOPPING TRUMPED, WISE DOWN THE
SIDELINES LIKE A COWARD?
IF NOT YOU, THEN WHO?
HAVE YOU SEEN THE DEMOCRATS?
YOU ARE THE ONLY HOPE YOUR PARTY
HAS.
THERE IS NO ONE BETTER.
THAT'S WHY I AM STARTING THE
DRAFT ALEC 2020 CAMPAIGN.
I INVITE VIEWERS TO JOIN.
LET'S MAKE HIM THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE BECAUSE ALEC, YOU HAVE
TAKEN YOUR SHOTS.
TIME TO SETTLE THIS ONCE AND FOR
ALL.
THE ONLY REASON WHY YOU WON'T IS
BECAUSE YOU ARE SCARED OF
LOSING.
WHAT DID YOU JUST SAY BEFORE?
>> IF IRAN FOR PRESIDENT, I
WOULD WIN HANDS DOWN.
>> Greg: DANA, THIS IS EXACTLY
WHAT WE NEED.
>> Dana: I AGREE.
LET'S HAVE SOMEONE FROM
HOLLYWOOD RUN AND SETTLE THIS
QUESTION.
>> Greg: IF HE IS SUCH A
PATRIOT AND BELIEVES IN HIS
HEART TRUMP IS EVIL, HE IS THE
MAN.
>> Dana: ABSOLUTELY.
#2020AlecBaldwin.
>> Greg: HE IS AN ENTERTAINER.
HE HAD A TV SHOW.
HE'S LIKE TRUMP.
>> Juan: DID YOU EVER SEE THE
FILM IDIOCRACY?
TWO PEOPLE UNQUALIFIED.
ALEC BALDWIN SAYS I'M A BETTER
ENTERTAINER, BETTER ACTOR.
THE ONLY, HE SAID HE THINKS
TRUMP WILL FIRE MUELLER.
HE  HE SAID HE THINKS TRUMP SAID
HE  HE SAID HE THINKS TRUMP SAIT
HE  HE SAID HE THINKS TRUMP SAIO
KIM, JUST SAY YOU'RE GOING TO
DENUCLEARIZE BECAUSE I NEED
THAT.
IT'S LIKE AN ABSURDITY.
IT'S A JOKE.
THE THING IS, WE ARE ALL LIVING
THROUGH IT.
>> Greg: I COULD SEE IT,
KIMBERLY.
HE'S THE FACE OF THE RESISTANCE.
HE PLAYS TRUMPET EVERY SATURDAY.
>> Kimberly: YOURE SAYING
SADDLE UP.
>> Greg: PUT YOUR MONEY WHERE
YOUR MOUTH IS.
>> Kimberly: WOULD YOU LOOK AT
THE CAST OF CHARACTERS OF
ALTERNATIVES, WHO ARE YOU GOING
TO HAVE?
WOULD SEAN PENN BE ON THE LEAD
IN THAT TICKET OR BALDWIN?
WHO WOULD YOU HAVE?
THE ONLY THING PROBABLY, THE
ONLY ONE PROBABLY IS
OPRAH WINFREY.
ALEC BALDWIN WILL BE ABSOLUTELY
ENTERTAINING.
>> Jesse: I WOULD SAY WE HAVE
FINALLY FOUND A CANDIDATE WHO
HATES REPORTERS MORE THAN TRUMP.
DIDN'T BALDWIN PUNCH REPORTERS
IN THE FACE?
TRUMP HASN'T EVEN DONE THAT.
I LISTEN TO THE INTERVIEW LIVE.
I LOVE HOWARD.
HOWARD WAS TOUGH AND FAIR.
HE DIDN'T REALLY TAKE ASIDE.
HE WAS ON FOR AN HOUR AND A
HALF, KEPT STEERING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MUELLER.
HE THINKS THERE'S SECRET
"APPRENTICE" TAPES THAT ARE
LONG-LOST.
HE LOOKS LIKE A PRESIDENT, JUST
LOOKING AT HIM.
I KIND OF LIKE HIM WHEN I
LISTEN.
BALDWIN.
I CAN SEE THEM IN THE
OVAL OFFICE.
IF HE DID RUN FOR PRESIDENT, HE
WOULD SPEND THE ENTIRE SUMMER IN
THE HAMPTONS.
HE SAYS HIS WIFE WOULDN'T BE
WITH IT.
>> Juan: TRUMP HAS EXECUTIVE
TIME.
HE SPENDS THE MORNINGS AND THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Greg: HE HOSTS TV SHOWS.
HE IS A BRASH NEW YORKER.
KNOWN AMONG THE LADIES.
HUGE EGO AND A COLORFUL PAST.
IF YOU KNOW 100% OR 1000% YOU
CAN WIN, THEN RUN.
WHAT IS IT, ALEC?
I KNOW HE WATCHES THIS SHOW.